okay so welcome back so in the
construction that we saw saw so far in
the public parameters i was giving an
encoding a1 and a0 test parameter okay
and I described that you could sample
you can do the quality test given these
parameters now let me describe a problem
with the scheme as such the scheme that
I've described so far is not secure okay
so in particular I will talk about the
setting when even then the zero test
parameter is not given you know at least
in that setting the scheme should be
secure even in that setting the DD h
problem is not yet secure so let's see
so if i wanted to generate a challenge
for the DD h attacker i would want to
give him an encoding of a random s
encoding of a random plain text element
tea and encoding of the product a
facility or a random value are well how
could i generate them well i could
generate a random sample CS without
knowing s i could also generate a random
sample CT without knowing tea and also
the last one CR I don't know how to
generate CST because I don't know I
centene the other secret parameters well
one easy ways i can multiply csn CT well
okay fine let's go ahead we can encode
the the value s at level 1 by
multiplying CS would lie similarly I can
encode at this value T by multiplying
CTU dry and then ust as well okay well
what's the problem well you could check
if you st is the product of us and UT /
y so i just solve the DDA's problem even
without the zero test so what's the
problem the problem is that what I'm
giving is when I'm giving an encoding of
CST R it corresponds to an encoding
which is very algebraically which is
closely related to the encoding of cs
and CP that encoding of S&T that i'm
giving up we need to rerun demise the
encoding that is being given out to
break the score relationship and so in
particular I have the set s 1 s Steve
and I give you a state corresponds to a
fixed point within this set perhaps or
low noise one that's fine
but the specific point that is is
closely tied with the encoding is us and
UT okay instead what I would like to
give is I would like to give a random
encoding within this space ok so in I
would like to move from this point to
another point in the same set which is
not algebraically related to these
anymore and does not have the noise much
larger than the point I started with and
the idea to do that is is very simple
sort of going back towards we were
stalked yesterday in both docs the rot
Willemse idea extends in this setting if
I was to publish and coatings or
encryptions of 0 in the public
parameters that is values from the set s
10 x0x0 prime ins and so on then I could
just add a random linear combination of
these values to this original blue point
that I started with and obtain a
somewhat random value that caused that
color that represents the same plain
text element s plus St and it no longer
has the algebraic relationship that it
had with the original us and UT and we
can hope for the DDA's problem to be
hard ok and if you wanted to read and
demise you can keep doing that by adding
random linear combinations of these in
coatings of 0 again and again ultimate
the noise would go but that's fun to
make or if you're giving the challenge
element to make everything look sort of
have the same noise bound you could also
read an demise you are to the same noise
level if you were if you were giving you
are instead of the USD ok yes yeah so
this this this process is actually buy
off adding random linear combination get
you something statistically close to
sampling at random from the
corresponding numerator in the encoding
from from a large enough or a boundary
by adding these random readers you get
something that is statistically closed
from sampling directly from the ride set
with the appropriate distribution so you
can define a distribution that will be
the same a in it was first done by
agarwal at all other while gently halevi
sigh agarwal and they gave but a
different agarwal so yeah ok so the
encoding so far the parameters i have i
have an encoding of one i have a bunch
of encoding of 0 which are essential for
anonymization and i have a encoding of
the 0 test parent oh sorry 0 Perez
barometer to encode a random element I
sample a see which is going to be small
and going to correspond to a random
corset I multiply it with the level 1
encoding a one getting the encoding and
then re randomize it with these encoding
of 0 ok hey I could if I'm just given an
encoding and my goal is to just three
randomized I can take it and and read
randomize it as well this grows the
noise but hopefully not too much the 0
testing itself works as follows you map
the the element that you're given to
level K so you multiply it by to the J
for an appropriate take it to the
highest level which is the the level K
and check a few times the 0 testing
parameter is small if it is small good
it's an encoding of 0 otherwise not ok
so k is the level of multilinear publish
only one to the cages you know you
multiplied by Z 2 Z K yes so this is the
value but you can give k in the clear
it's the system parameter you can
multiply it with one and take it to the
final level you can artificially raise
it to the highest level and then do the
test it so when your civilization is not
needed for applications like obfuscation
encoding it
what do you mean in terms of you just
put the encoding procedure you describe
its variants sampling from some funky
distribution yeah so so let me answer
that so in office Cashin what happens is
i have a bunch of things that I in cord
and I give these to you now the security
requirement is that you cannot tell how
I generated those encoding but when you
have I didn't I don't need to give you
in coatings of zero to be able to read
and demise those terms and give to
someone else that has never needed but
you do need to at the very least assume
that that funky encoding distribution is
hard to invert is so so a the encoding
of zero do not need to be provided when
I was generating myself if i was to
assume that the thing is generating your
self you just don't test them I just
don't I mean I don't even have to
generate them myself because I'm even
the generator of all the system
parameters I know everything in the wool
so I can generate everything and give to
you whatever you like it is fresh it's
fresh it's not even it I don't even have
to read under my you could have smaller
parameters perhaps for better efficiency
but you don't even have to have any
randomization there yeah a of course if
you're trying to base it on a office
keishon syndrome simpler assumptions and
you want to claim that you the
securities based on those simpler
assumptions then you might internally
use the randomization and then you might
have yes yes it seems like your encoding
and auditory lse and so this is the
thing so you sample a random see but you
good at what you could be given see
people oh you could do that as well I
see so so this gives a public procedure
to encode at level 1 any element of your
choice if you're given the small hey if
you're given by an exercise but if so
how would you in code what do you mean
by C has to be sampled right okay right
like I mean if someone gives you see ya
sure I can do that but if you tell me
for 793 the sea is this
level zero sampling yes computing an
encoding of something that you wanted
level zero that's harder than yes yes
yes so says you can push things up and
then do it by a traitor yeah so we have
a encoding on one in the public primary
right what right so this video animation
is not needed for office kitchen has
just explained and as we'll see these in
courting of zero are what make a lot of
the attacks work and so these office
kitchen schemes are so resilient to
those attacks yeah so too so in
particular for an office kitchen scheme
you don't need it you can even through
the encoding one any other questions ok
so there the bunch of variants that you
can imagine i'll just briefly mention
them so you can have a symmetric variant
so in bovina maps you have the
asymmetric version instead of having the
same Z you could have bunch of different
Z eyes and this would mimic the
symmetric or external difficult among
assumptions and so on you can come up
with all kinds of assumptions and so for
that you could give an encoding of y for
each of the CI so this will correspond
to the generator for each of the groups
you could give in coatings of 0 in each
of the four each of the the groups as
well so you can read randomized in each
one of them and then the 0 testing
parameter would look something like s
time is the product of all the Z is so
if you have you want to check zeros at
the highest level you have to DZ eyes
will cancel out in the zero testing and
everything else will remain the same you
can have something pitchers partially
symmetric and partially asymmetric I
haven't seen an application yet that
fully uses it so that would be really
nice if you have an application that
uses the full power okay so now let me
move on to the attack attack's for it
for the GES scheme the way I'm going to
start by talking about is the week
discrete log attack let me start by the
discrete log what does it mean so in
this scheme I had these
the simple variant for the symmetric
setting I have an encoding of one bunch
of encoding of 0 and then in the 0 test
parameter and these are something that
can be removed if you're looking at some
of the applications for example office
keishon you get to Z or Z would become
would be to completely break the system
okay if you were to remove the zero test
then it's something very similar to the
egg true problem in soft believe that
security should hope so what's making
all the attacks possible is going to be
this this additional one parameter that
we're giving away it's off like the
secret key but noisy with the etch
factor there so the entire security
hinges on that for a discreet prob if
computing discrete log means the
followings if I give you an encoding you
which is C by Z where C is something
small if you can find C prime equal to C
mod G where C prime is also relatively
small then that would constitute as
finding the discrete log of this
encoding ok we've discrete log will will
be something where you can find C prime
which is allowed to be large but still
less than Q so let's say order square
root key and here's how the attack
proceeds so let me compute F which is y
times so you time to use the encoding
that I want to attack times X I which is
an encoding of 0 NE pick any one of them
times y to the power k minus 2 so why is
just an encoding of one exponentiated k
minus 22 may take this entire value to
the KH level so this is a level one
encoding level one encoding level K
minus n1 encode let k minus 2 encoding
the whole thing is a level K encoding
and I multiply it with the 0 test permit
ok what this relates to you is C by Z so
the entire computation is done in our
queue times bi bi z which is the
encoding of 0 and bi is from the ideal
times a to the K minus two divided by Z
to the K minus two x HZ k x z and when
you do the computation which you're left
with is c times
bi bi G AK minus 2 times edge so C and
AK minus 2 are both small bi bi G is
going to be small because bi isn't the
ideal and we also require the G in words
were small NK and as is the only large
quantity so i'm left with c times Delta
and this whole even though large it's
off size square root cube so what I was
able to compute was not necessary
computer times a fixed value that does
not depend on any of the parameters
ability to be including itself yes when
you say / g you mean g inverse over our
cue yes so i should have had that these
operations are being done in our queue
and I so all these are done in our queue
and I'm saying this quantity is now
small it's smaller than square root koo
so therefore it's the same in our Q&R
why is it small because G inverse of RR
q is not necessarily small problem
possibly can so bi isn't the ideal right
so it's in the ideal and it so it's it's
some something times G and so right so
this these operations went on an
arguably to c times delta and this
quantity is of size that's a square root
kill then this value is same both in our
Q and R and so I have basically gotten
what my goal was which was to compute C
prime such that it's a it's it's a cheap
rhyme is well roughly I got that I have
a delta factor extra and it sort of size
square root encoding with you yes yes
yes yes yes but the encoding on one is
so it's not very important because you
could have at just random encoding than
that would have to build yes you need
the encoding of 0 that's the most
crucial right so this does not
immediately break em ddh but it does
break the deal in problem okay so it
already gives you an attack you can
express all the encoding zaz a find the
discrete log of all of them and you just
have to check if the determinant of some
matrix is you and you can do that
ok ok so this attack can be extended to
other setting where zeros are not
explicitly provided this is a recent
attack by Corona at all it sort of
doesn't provide zeros in the clear but
the encoding czar sort of sufficient and
offer gendrich enough to be able to
somehow implicitly provide a zero that
still enables this test ok I'm not going
to go into the details of this this pets
or the the key highlight of this result
is it works without zeros but the zeros
are somehow implicitly are given in
encoding that are given up again
precedes voice you know taking the
application constructing an encoding of
zero and planning this no so the thing
is then you take the product in the end
you have an encoding of zero you don't
have an encoding of zero at any level
you can't construct an encoding of you
but you have an encoding of implicitly
mimic making this behavior we have
encoding of zero in the final product
the this attack was further extended to
a total break if you're given zeros very
decently by when gia where if you are
given encoding 20 not just you you're
not just computing this as something of
reasonable size of square root q But off
sighs which is small actually small you
computing discrete log which allows you
to break if you have ok ok so one quick
point I wanna mention is that the the
new CLT scheme which are not going to
talk about but perhaps incredibly point
might mention a little bit about it is
that the fix that they have for well I
guess I get to it that the scheme with
the zeros there is a new candidate fix
for gghs well so it's open to
investigation let's see if you can find
attacks or learn something from it and
perhaps argue something about security
to make sure i understand coz this game
is that you presented completely broken
but it's useful for something else no no
no so this candidate if you are giving
away zeros is broken what you're saying
will be used for the randomization c49
the magician it's nieces it's not yeah
so it's it there are two classes of
applications office keishon like
applications and another class of
application the class of applications
like office keishon a the no attacks
which which affect them in any way for
the other classes of applications we
have these attacks which break them and
there is a tentative fix as of now I to
do that I complications yeah something
beyond using on reruns musician or not
um no it's the zeros basically yeah yeah
yeah yeah that you use randomization or
not quite right yes the fix for GTA okay
okay okay yeah sort of it's not in that
time quite well that's okay so they're
the new fix that they have are there was
a appendix which said for ggh it didn't
make strong claims it said that the
security needs to be analyzed and it's
just saying that for the CLT it works
through the ggh they have removed that
they're not confident about that right
fix for ggh so they have the fix for CLT
but I'll get to that yeah but in some
settings what's the difference with
those savings and obfuscation when you
don't have to do so as I said you're not
giving 0 explicitly but what ends up
happening is giving a 0 in a in an
implicit fashion and for office keishon
seems we sort of that kind of a feature
does not arise is it because our
prescription is like it designated
that's because in the designated setting
is because you're not giving any zeros
but that is sort of slightly different
from this question in the sense of all
why doesn't this setting yeah yes well
for the zeros yes yeah okay yes
heuristic Lee are you can do everything
here is the query everything yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes yeah wait while you
ristic alee provably from BBB from BBB
but we don't have vbb yeah yes yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay
okay so let me move on to the CLT
construction i'll describe the
construction it sort of builds upon very
naturally on the the gdh construction
and i'll describe the attack in that
setting so like describe the extension
of the week discrete log that I that I
explained the this specific attack turns
out to be more devastating for CLT in
the center it breaks the scheme
completely when the zeros are provided
well as for ggh with the new attack
though yeah functionality somehow
requires that you get that goings of the
same ailment writer in there is a
program that two inputs it evaluate to
the same output you're saying that only
happens right that gives me an according
of zero so they the output and course it
so yes yes yes oh of course at the level
the last level in encoding of zero is
not really counted yeah yeah that's not
counted yeah yeah yeah yeah so you
crucially using the chocolate that's you
it is in the sense right so that's what
the the attack for the nonzero ones all
right yes hello five including moves you
and just previous attacks what does it
break with breaks nothing so little 1.10
break stuff you get what level five
encoding of zero so it will break stuff
so it will break stuff okay at the top
of my head I can say it will break
certainly break some assumptions I'm not
sure if we'll break all the assumption
that the the level because you can't
compute the discrete log off the levels
which are below that level well I mean
if you have let's say that the level of
multi linearity was seven and you had
encoding it at the fifth level and you
want to compute a week discrete log or
the discrete log itself of another
encoding at level five that seems hard
because you can't multiply them to then
multiply with the zero test does make
sense
alright so you're saying it's not the
stars of your that you can break
decreases exponentially there's a level
of 0 is the most part anything below the
top level is pretty better yeah yeah so
I guess I but you could pick split hairs
between right okay so let me move to the
CLT construction and in this setting
we're going to work over a modulus end
which is highly composite so the product
of primes p 1 2 pn we're going to assume
that factoring n is hard and the pis are
all this out of the same size okay i'm
going to use it the Chinese remainder
theorem at representational a lot in
this just like the previous scheme where
i had the g + z being hidden by the
public parameter scheme i'm now going to
have the public matter meters hide the p
is a similar parameters e which is going
to be the masking parameter again sample
from ZN and a parameter GI which is
going to be much much less than PR ok
the plain text values are going to be t
vectors unlike the previous case where
they were the closets of I in this case
they're going to be the vectors alpha 1
to alpha T which come from z g one g g
two up to z GT ok and you can naturally
define additional multiplication
operations or these in a component in
twice fashion so you could if you had
given two vectors you can add them
component wise and you get in the
addition and can multiply them component
wise also to get a product so let's see
while the CLT construction looks like i
have the sets s 0 1 s 0 2 and so on I'm
going to just like before i'm going to
sample a small element in s0 to if i
want to encode to what so here one tues
are up to G somehow represent the
displaying pic space so I'm sort of
linearizing this this vector space ok so
for example 0 0 0 represents this plane
txt space and so on
and if I want to encode this this
element too i generate see as the CRT of
e1 to ET where each of the eyes is
generated as false so let me describe
what they are GI is a fixed quantity i
sample a random RI which is small enough
at alpha i geti I and then i compute the
CRT of all all these values ok where CIT
of you 12 ET is the element model with
the CRT decomposition so if if you were
to take C and take mod p I then you will
get e I thank you just make sure so you
including elemento see em so I'm
encoding an element in here right yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah yes put a little
noise and you could do it yeah so this
is a small element and the smallness is
but babe like this size of I alright ok
what's the other breaks lecture over the
plain text space so you can add them up
right there if you add them up you get
the component wise addition and
component wise multiple inverses uh yeah
yeah on this it's your hey hey what's
with you
the CI values are going to be much
smaller than the P is so if you take see
mod so these are so judgy eyes are
chosen to be smaller than P I much
smaller than P I I think polynomial
right size of this great apartment yeah
yeah play so don't you no need to grow
oh yeah I guess not yeah so alpha is the
plain text element that I'm encoding
here right so encoding is going to
proceed in sort of exactly the same way
once you have the CRT number see you
just divide by Xion in ZN and then you
get the encoding of alpha 1 to alpha T
and you can keep do so all eyes are
small as well so holy eyes are small yes
yeah and then you divide by z square and
you get the level 2 encoding and you can
go further based on ah it's the same
thing with yeah I mean you a you can
call it division here you can in
multiplication in the 0 test parameter
yeah but but you're going to have
something things yeah yeah yeah also if
you had that multiplication here you
have to have it divided on the zero test
it's like okay so if ccrt of alpha and
these a CRT of beta so if you obtain
these represent using this procedure and
II eyes are short then if you were to
add the encoding than the sum of the
encoding is just like before is going to
be small as well in particular each of
the e is so the e is corresponding to
see and the ear is corresponding to D
when you add them up the Sun will remain
small with respect to each of the P is
similarly multiplication so so far what
we have we have engine
if I want to give a level kk encoding of
alpha it has the form Z by Z K for a
short c where c is generated at CRT p 1
to N and each of the EIS is a is some
small encoding of l5 with some random
noise multiple up to you if you want to
add you can just add like before
multiplication also precedes the same
way this gives a somewhat homomorphic
importing and just like before we have a
mechanism to remember how many
operations have been performed what we
need to do is sampling any quality check
in the the CLT scheme sampling at level
0 is very similar to the rear animas
ation of tgh in particular the public
parameters include level zero in
coatings of random plain text elements
so pick a random alpha 1 to alpha T
values and just your level zero and
coatings of that if you want to encode a
random element just take random linear
combination a so this gives a level 0
encoding of a random plain text element
if you wanna encoded higher level
included encoding a one you can multiply
with an encoding of one and to get an
encoding of that random element that you
just have yeah you know mean it's
somehow it has to grow some what to do
to make the argument but it doesn't it
always remains smaller than the
parameters remain smaller than the p.i
then you make sure that they don't go
beyond uniform a few so in this case
they had a slightly different argument
it was the leftover hash lemma were
these lattices but sort of works in all
this way the the same argument that was
there would also work here arm but they
have a sort of and I think this argument
also work for d th that's also argue
that the Playtex to get is random yes
yes
yes and if you want to read an demise
the encoding that you just got by
multiplying with an encoding one you
just pop include public in coatings of
zero these are going to be very
devastating but you could do that and so
now let me describe how the CLT zero
test work so I'm going to define p I
start to be n divided by P I for each
other so n was the pre call that n was
the product of all the pi so pi star is
all of them except pi/4 any even two ET
we have you can observe the fact that if
you take the CRT of the product to p 1
star with the one and so on this is
exactly computes to the summation of pi
star e I modern okay so in particular if
you were to take this number mod p I
what you're going to get all the terms
are going to to get zero doubt because
each of all the terms except the pif
term is going to get zero doubt because
they have a multiple of P I and the only
term that survives is PI star here you
and the CCL t0 test parameter consists
of this quantity P 1 star h1z1 inverse
and so on CRT of this times this element
ZK computation being done in NZ n where
each of the sietch eyes is much smaller
than the pie
so the zero test procedures follow so if
you're given an encoding of zero at
level K and as the form it's going to
have the form CRT of g 1 r 1 and so on
so note that all the alpha is r0 loud
right so here each each encoding look
like a ir IGI since it's an encoding of
0 alpha is a 0 so each AI is exactly our
idea so what you're going to do is
you're going to multiply the 0 test
parameter with this encoding you and
what it evaluates to is CRT of p1 star H
1 R 1 so the ZK part cancels out and the
g 1 and g one in verses or GI inverses
cancel out ah but since each of the etch
I the product s IR I is less than then p
I we have that p I star hir I is less
than n right since n was the product of
all the pies and if you take the sum
over all the eyes this is going to be
small as well so you multiply the two
just like before if the the value comes
out to be small then this is indeed an
encoding of 0 and and and not otherwise
so is this clear ok if it's not an
encoding of something was not in
recording of 0 then if one or at least
one of the the elements in alpha would
be such that alpha is not equal to 0 and
the corresponding gene in GI inverse
term will not cancel out and we'll have
at least one of the terms being large
and so ok so initially these are for the
zeroing attacks so well for CLT nggh if
we weren't to publish the zero test
parameter that we what would we be able
to reduce reduce security to welcome if
we didn't reduce too evident publish the
0-10 essentially into it's essentially a
0 in CLT uh I would guess so ya know
yes yes some sort of here but if
approximately PD is false than ten
syllables that we do that yeah some for
some range of parameters we can even
reduce these days okay but we have no
applications of the zero test right no
just to get off what we are off oh here
the zero without the digital test I
heard you know where it's where we think
security maybe come without the zero
test essentially somewhat Toma morphic
encryption right okay so they did not
initially they were not it didn't seem
like we could extend the week discrete
log attack that I described but see on
at all extended these attacks in
breaking a CLT in the case went
according to zero provided just to
stress again coatings are only provided
for some of the applications and not
necessarily all so now let me describe
the geometric at all attack and see how
it works so an encoding of so in the
rest of the the slide the encoding is in
red are the ones that I'm going to
attack so in encoding V of alpha 1 1230
looks something like c by Z for a short
c where c is where it's the Chinese
remainder theorem representation of e1
Tweety where each of the eyes is
obtained as our I time Zi plus alpha
okay for short i'm going to denote this
V as being ii 1 this as a vector e1 to
ET okay so finding the EIS would be
breaking the scheme completely since
each of the EIS is less less than P I we
have that these values are actually
unreduced so even though the computation
here is being done in in ZN when I'm
represent making this notation I expect
these guys to be the actual ones not the
these are unreduced values if you is an
encoding of 0 all in coatings of 0 are
going to be represented with the green
color
look something like AG one x a comma up
to 80 GT right so it just looks like a
and encoding like as we it's a special
case if we accept all the alphas are 0
so I have each of the eyes is some
random multiple of GR then small random
multiple appear so 0 tests on you gives
me summation of Delta ie I so in
particular the z pack will cancel out
and the g g inverse will cancel out and
what i'm left with is a summation of the
AIS and some extra parameter Delta I
denoted they're different different
color because it's independent of the
encoding you at hand particular it's
it's only the value P I start times H I
what do you mean by the ear test give
something it's so when you multiply you
with the zero test parameter the product
yields this value so it is some
particular version of a zero test
exactly the one that I ya know just
abstract your test oh no no no yeah so
exactly that one yes yeah there and note
that this value is is unreduced because
use in encoding of see you right ok so
now i have to attack encodings v and v
prime both in red i have i'm given an
encoding of 0 and i'm going to assume
some filler encoding RW c 12 CT whatever
it is and this is going to be so let's
say these all encoding you're at level 1
this will also level 1 this is a filler
encoding which takes the product to the
highest level ok so if i was to take the
product uvw what I'm going to get is a 1
times v1 times c1 the three times g 1
and and so on ok and this is at the
chaos level so if it was level 1 level 2
1 I could take the filler encoding to be
at level K mine k minus 2 i delayed this
and similarly I can generate UV prime W
which is exactly the same quantity
except that the bees are replaced with
v1 Prime and so on and this this UV W is
is
is since there is a G term hear it it's
actually looks like an encoding of 0 at
the gate level it's an encoding of 0 at
the theater if I was to apply 0 test on
it what I'm going to get is the encoded
value the g's are going to go away times
R Delta right so if you were to take an
encoding of zero when you take the the
multiplied with the zero test the value
that you get is summation i delta AI the
g parts go away and similarly if i was
to take this quantity and multiply i get
the summation AI bi CI times delta which
can be written as multiplication of this
vector a times this matrix times
multiplication of this vector C and this
is a diagonal matrix with the diagonal
entries being bi Delta so and all the
quantities here are unreduced modern so
there's no everything was small we
multiplied with the zero test and said
it was an encoding of 0 everything
should be small similarly if I was to do
the same thing for V Prime I'll get the
dish I could at this point instead of
just taking one element for instead of
just taking one you I could take
multiple samples for you and multiple
choices for W and it would give me not
just one summation here but a matrix of
elements right so i could take bunch of
values of you we is exactly this matrix
and I get a matrix you will you has rows
consisting of encoding the 0 so I was
there was a row of and cool I could take
multiple rows of encoding to 0 and c is
multiple columns of filler encodings so
i have i'm repeating the same process
again and again to get now the same
thing in a matrix form now that I'm have
the matrices y and y prime what i could
do is i take y times y prime inverse and
if you were to take the inverse here
it the C in C inverse will cancel out
and the diagonal matrices will get the
diagnosis their diagonal matrices the
the diagonal entries will will get
divided so what I will be left with VA
times v1 divided by v1 Prime and so on
times a inverse so for this matrix here
that I have the values since it's a
diagonal matrix the elements on the
diagonal are exactly the eigen values of
this matrix entrance multiplying with
A&A inversion the eigenvalues of this
final matrix are also going to be the
same during that I can once i have
access to this matrix now i can compute
the the eigen values of this matrix e bi
bi bi Prime okay and this is enough to
wireless security of many assumption you
can also factor once you have access to
this value you can factor in as well and
it sort of leads to a complete break the
attack was extended just in a similar
way if you're not given zeros but sort
of implicit the zeros are present this
attack can be extended the to the CLT
setting as well and but they just very
recently in a new version of the scheme
by a by CLT sort of prevents these
attacks even when encoding 20 or
provider and it sort of works by making
the scheme significantly less linear and
sort of seems to be a really a new idea
in terms of its not the redhawk fixed
but sort of a there's something or at
least seemingly something new going on
but sort of trying to prevent this
attack sort of give you a rough idea if
you were to look at these we're trying
to solve so many questions here what CLT
15 does is so makes these equations
noisy to solve I will not talk about it
but I think think creatively point will
mention it the in stock okay so here's
the summary of the current constructions
and yeah by saying that basically the
codec so she also physically so think
about a setting if you have composite
order thing going on and you're not
giving in coatings of 0 at the in each
any any place you have to multiply a
bunch of in cordage to get an encoding
of 0 at the top level but what's left in
addition to the 0 is a meaningful
quantity that you would want to attack
does make sense you don't know that you
would like to find what it is it's kind
of things can be fixed in the
application oh it can be a lot of fun
but in terms of what's what won't work
is um in fact I'm not even sure if was
there a specific application that this
broke these for specific things that
they did work so I'm not aware of for
like if there was a specific application
where these attacks did break something
they broke those assumptions but there
was an application based on those
assumptions right there's a huge family
of assumption that you can make and what
we're ruling out that these assumptions
don't work but there weren't any
applications based on okay so so far we
have three candidate constructions on
when is this ideal lattice based one
which I described and the CLT one at the
new CLT one if you care about giving out
zeros and not the as well and a
graph-based multi linear map scheme by
Gentry Gordon over levee that I did not
talk at all about the for the vi v LS
space scheme initially we had a weak
discrete log attack given zeros this is
not applicable for obfuscation there is
a quantum attack that was recently found
by kramer at all this extends to a sub
exponential classical attack in
particular 2 to the N part 2 by 3 as
well so this relates to finding
principle short given a principle idea
you can find a short representation for
that I did not talk about these
the work by corona tall extended it to
the setting the week discrete log attack
to some setting without the zeros and
who GI extend the week discrete log
attack to a total break when you given
the zeros for the CLT case it since
relies on factoring we already had a
quantum attack given zeros based on the
unit tall attack we can get a total
break in parallel of this attack exists
here as well there's a new fix for CLT
which is appearing in crypto this year
and as I said there seems to be
something really new going on and the
kind of attacks that we have don't they
don't seem to work there it doesn't
necessarily work for ggh was just
pointed for the grab graph-based demo CD
maps it's completely open to
investigation these are not there they
don't get full blown multilinear maps
but they are sufficient for various
applications such as office keishon and
for these we don't even know a quantum
attacks so it's completely open yeah
that's inherent in some sense to go to
the maps so I think different people
have different opinions on it there is
there isn't a formal answer but the
schemes do look very non lattice like I
don't exactly how you define it like it
somehow the noise can save you or
something like that because I mean
this enough right for quantum attack is
that oh yeah but its sub exponential oh
well quantum okay thank you yeah yeah
yes forever right but that's all saves
you yeah you're saying if we had like
perfect multi linear map then inherently
there would be a quantum attack but for
this noisy very good yeah so noisy
version there is an attack right I mean
if you can do semper should be many
operation yeah yeah yeah yeah so the
aisle is sort of not so say any of the
candidates has have been proposed so far
there haven't been any attack that has
sort of improved on any for the
classical setting there's no new
improvement in terms of attack in any
sense for any candidate has been sort of
proposed so far yeah construction has
some of the plate or other instructions
Aristo Leah so it's actually the most
different so it's a relies on structure
closer to the lwe and stuff is somewhat
different yeah yes yes yes but this is
sort of completely open I don't think
they're there aren't any quantum attacks
either for this right okay yeah okay so
I talked about these two attacks but I
think so the bottom line is that they
there's there's a lot going on and both
the constructions like the stakes are
very high we really need to have these
constructions we get application which
were really are believed to be
impossible are now made possible once
you have access to these and this
investigation is is is going on and
we're learning a lot
in both areas of attacks as well as
constructions are very much benefiting
from this research and I said multi new
maps are very useful it's a very active
area of investigation a tax break some
hardness assumptions but not all for
example obfuscation is unaffected one
sad part is the whips weariness somewhat
of a break and repair situation and what
is really missing is a 2d to guide their
or a strongly established some
confidence in the security of how we
build these constructions so hopefully
that is something that the future work
will will will answer any questions
Washington without and the importance of
you an argument hours right for
improving their sort of impulsively
given up but not explicitly no no so
what what kind of applications does that
include so that's what I said I I don't
know offer any is it oh you can take the
simplified variant of Zimmerman's
sophistication and break that up ever
know yeah okay so that you can break you
can take the applications for very
simple branch and program and break that
the things that you can do actually
location so that one requires egos not
that but that that one requires eaters
who is asking about an application that
doesn't require zeros and is broken yeah
yeah if you makes me so the principles
liquid state
of a special scheme and actually still
use the original series and yes yeah no
not the original TLT because they did
have encoding 20 right they were
constructing office keishon from a
simple assumption so when you're going
to start with that assumption you have
to do reran demise ation yeah we're
going to no better no better so if we
will not that's an indication of
something that's also something
situation cannot go on for very long
right yeah yeah I always surviving
please
again